you want a micro dose yes yeah I thought
so two please
pop up thank you
thank you baby of course
do you know what turned me on
when Lexi dropped that baby
no no
what turned me on was when I realized
that that's something you would never do
I would never do that how could you ever
drop a baby I don't know I don't have to
cradle all the babies I do and all I
have to do is take care of everyone else
and it's really hard well
because you are the light
no no no no I mean
we could we could we
should we should we drop a baby
should we drop a baby in the show
we could drop a baby in the show you
could drop a baby in the show but I feel
really bad I feel really bad I don't
want Lex to feel like we stole the story
from her it's gonna feel very directly
related to what happened Lex is a writer
true and you know she understands Talent
she understands the Muse when when the
spirit speaks you have to listen wow
that's true right and also she dropped a
baby like she's cathartic for her but
also how many people have dropped babies
we could say it's like public domains
yeah you know like happy birthday
I love it
[Music]